on September 6th Ukraine launched a
surprise counter-attack which has
overwhelmed Russian lines
this is the most serious military defeat
that Putin had faced in more than 20
years in power is a Ukrainian Victory on
the cards and how much could this damage
Putin's power in Russia
this has been one of the most successful
Ukrainian operations in six months of
war in the space of just over a week
Ukraine has liberated over 8 000 square
kilometers of territory which is an area
roughly the size of Cyprus there's the
Northeast around hakive it says
collapsed for the Russians in
spectacular fashion this week There's
the eastern part of the front in donbass
where the Russians have been attempting
to make games in Donetsk Province
without much success and there's the
South around kerson and zaporizia where
the ukrainians have been conducting
another major counter-offensive over the
past couple of weeks so all in all this
is an incredibly successful offensive in
military terms and I think it is a
humiliation for the Russian army in
symbolic terms as well the atmosphere in
cave which is where I am at the moment
is actually very interesting I mean
there is no
um Euphoria about this uh this Victory I
think there is obviously people are very
pleased they almost don't want to curse
it they
um they're being very composed obviously
very encouraged by what they're seeing
there is a bit of exhibition of Rusty
and destroyed Russian armor in the
center of cave and there are more people
taking their kids to see Russian tanks
but they are being very careful uh in
not uh over building it and I think that
in itself is actually a good and
encouraging sign
foreign foreign
to Ukraine over the past six months has
been in my opinion the biggest the most
ambitious the most intense flow of arms
to any country in such a short period of
time since the second world war and it's
made a huge difference to these offenses
and I'd point to three different areas
weapons ammunition and intelligence
weapons have been absolutely essential
for example in the most recent harkiv
offensive Ukrainian officials tell us
that
anti-radiation missiles provided by
America have been vital to taking out
Russian air defense radars offensives
are also incredibly demanding in terms
of the ammunition that you use you end
up using far more bullets shells
um Rockets than you would when you're on
the defense and so maintaining a supply
of those uh vital shells rounds bullets
has been key to allowing Ukraine to go
on the offensive Western intelligence to
Ukraine has been crucial in identifying
Russian positions identifying Russian
movements and it's been intense
throughout this campaign but I think it
has stepped up in the last few weeks and
intelligence was really critical to
allowing Ukraine to catch Russia by
surprise in Hakeem as well
the reaction from the Kremlin
um has been in some ways very typical
that is when things are not going well
the Kremlin keeps actually silent
um it wasn't covering it all together
there were reports of Russian retreat
they called it regrouping rather than
running away from the enemy uh Vladimir
Putin himself tried to distance himself
from
um any uh commentary or from the war
itself Vladimir Putin spend that day
opening ferries will in the exhibition
sent in the theme park that actually
broke down very soon after he opened it
but even so it's clear that the anger is
building up and the anger not just
necessarily from the uh anti-war
part of the population from the Liberals
because they really have been uh
gagged and you know closed down
um and censored but actually very
interesting there is a lot of anger
coming from the right-wing nationalists
who are saying more radical uh war is
needed Russia should go further Russia
should escalate uh and they're starting
to blame Uh Russian command they're
starting to blame corruption in the
Russian
um Armed Forces uh and this is not
looking good for Putin
foreign
that could produce very serious anger
um particularly among the younger people
who would have to go and serve Russia is
a country with a demographic of 1.6
children per family we know from the
opinion polls that
um
the support for continuing this war is
actually waning particularly at the
younger part of the demographic so it
could have very unpleasant political
Fallout from him I don't know what
Shashank things about the actual how
much would it give him in terms of the
military Advantage at this stage in the
campaign I think the important thing to
remember is uh more soldiers more young
men isn't the end of Putin's problem he
has to find a way to train them to
organize them and to equip them and so
mobilization May yield him a bigger Army
but it will take many many months
perhaps over a year to fully feel its
effects and even then it won't
necessarily be an incredibly combat
effective Force
foreign
constant concerns over potential nuclear
escalation throughout this campaign and
in my opinion those concerns have been
somewhat over egged or overrated yes I
think there is apprehension that if
there is a sudden collapse of Russia's
armies and particularly if the Ukrainian
Army begins to threaten territory that
Russia considers to be a sovereign part
of Russia but I think we're some way
away from this at this point in time and
the risks of that course of action would
be enormous perhaps riskier than
grinding out the current path
foreign
Victory Is defined in many ways by
different participants in this conflict
but if we choose to Define it as Ukraine
restoring the borders that prevailed on
February 23rd the day before Vladimir
Putin began his invasion I think what
the significance of this offensive is is
not that it means Victory is around the
corner or that it means it means it's
imminent what it does is something in
some ways as important it shows us that
Victory Is Possible and it shows those
who doubted that Ukraine could dislodge
Russia that this was a a forlorn hope it
shows them that the war is winnable and
that message I think is of huge
inestimable value both for ukrainians
and for the International Community
supporting them through a winter that's
going to be difficult uh tough with high
gas prices with our cost of living
crisis it shows them that Victory is
also possible in pure military terms I
think Shashank is right I think the
retreat Now sort of beating Russians
back to the 20 third of February lines
is absolutely possible
and I think the world sees this and I
think Ukraine sees it Ukrainian goals
have changed in this campaign that
they're no longer going to be satisfied
with the restoring the status quo as was
on the 23rd of February they actually
want all of their territory back and
they think they can get it and they also
want Crimea back
which Russia annexed in 2014.
for Putin uh losing this battle
uh in the way that Ukraine defines it
would be the end of his regime uh would
be the end of the political system it
could be the end of Russia as we know it
at the moment Putin's legitimacy is
entirely based on his success on Victory
not just his actually this legitimacy of
all Russian rulers has been tied with
victories and successes
and he was considered to be lucky uh he
was always considered to be victorious
um so this is a big setback
um his legitimacy will suffer uh as a
result but Putin has been in power for
22 years
it's very hard for people to imagine
what Russia would look like without him
it's very hard at the moment to imagine
this this regime uh can actually
collapse uh suddenly and unexpectedly as
the Soviet one did as one
um
Anthropologist wrote about the Soviet
regime everything was forever until it
was no more when that moment comes we
can't say but surely this military
defeat uh brings one step closer to that
moment to read more of our coverage on
Ukraine including Pieces by Me by arcadi
in our fantastic colleagues in Ukraine
please click on the link and don't
forget to subscribe thank you very much
for watching